yo
out of here
oh my God glorilla's New York concert
leaves two women dead following a
stampede the rapper devastated by the
news this is a tragedy of epic
proportions and it's something that all
of us who love concerts worry about it
it happened Sunday night at the Main
Street Armory in Rochester a show that
also featured artists finesse two times
as fans exited there were reports of
what they believed to be gunshots inside
the venue which left people in a panic
yo
out of here
oh my God
on everything I love this would be the
last time I come to the main street I'm
Maria [__] Rochester for a concert
preliminary reports from people with the
scene indicate that these injuries were
caused from people being trampled
we do not have any evidence of gunshots
being fired or of anyone being shot or
stabbed at the scene police identified
one of the victims as 33 year old Ron
desia Belton of Buffalo the second woman
who died was said to be 35. meanwhile
several more concert goers were taken to
local hospitals to be treated for
injuries when you go to a concert you do
not expect
to be trampled
your loved ones expect you to be able to
come home
and talk about the experience that you
had at that great concert breaks my
heart
and it is totally unacceptable following
the event glorilla shared her
condolences on Twitter expressing that
she's devastated and heartbroken over
the tragic deaths quote my fans mean the
world to me praying for their families
and for a speedy recovery of everyone
affected E.T has reached out to both
glorilla and finesse two times Reps for
comment